well joining me now is Eric fer burn
founder and chief executive of electric
vehicle charging Network poor points
Eric good evening to you how many of
these points were going to need in 2040
then so a very large number is the
answer because what you have to remember
is that you don't you have a system a
bit like a petrol station in the future
in reality you're charging your car
wherever it parks so predominantly at
home in the workplace and also in public
space as well but very loosely I talk
about for every electric car that gets
sold about one and a half charging
points one at home certainly but then a
percentage share of workplace charging
and a percentage share of charging in
the public spaces so the number gets
quite big that's gonna be a nightmare
though isn't it in the street I don't
think it's going to be a nightmare I
think the product that you see in the
streets perhaps around London today
that's not what we're not going to see
one of those every other location you
know we're going to be much more
sympathetic to what that looks like but
the reality is each place you park is
going to have the facility to charge
your car in the future so the government
has said today it's going to put up a
hundred million pounds towards
supporting car charging infrastructure
is that enough so I think that that's
really a small amount versus what we
need to do but it's positive in reality
the government is not going to fund the
mass rollout of electric vehicle
charging it's going to be private
enterprises like what I do and they're
funding this so I think it's very
positive the government is good at
initiating this market but eventually
this is a you know a commercial rollout
on on commercial terms all right so I
mean what sort of returns are investors
going to be looking for to get their
money back if they put their money into
infrastructure fine so I mean you know
the number of different ways you can
fund this in terms of investment but
fundamentally you you've got an asset
putting an asset model in and you've got
an amount of energy which is provided by
that asset so you end up with a small
amount of margin on the energy which is
being supplied is we use to pay for the
rollout of that asset base so it's a
fairly you know fundamentally well
recognized model of how you roll a set
out but it is fundamentally commercial
you know I welcome a bit of government
investment but but really that's just to
get the industry early stage big
question though they say we've got at
the moment the government gets something
like 4% of all of its revenues from duty
on petrol and diesel sales it's going to
have to replace that so ultimately
electric cars are gonna have to be taxed
more on they I would agree I don't see
why moving to electric vehicles affects
the net tax day I think that tax take it
shouldn't and but obviously it comes
from slightly different air
so whether in the future we have a bit
of tax on electricity for electric
vehicles or whether we move to sort of
per mile based charging or whether we
move more to things like the congestion
charge I don't necessarily have the
answer of what the tax structure looks
like but I don't see that net it will be
any different the similar tax take will
come from the motorists in my opinion
moving forward all right Harry from Port
Point good to see thank you joining me